je me réjouis avec l'ensemble des
députés démocrates que nous ouvrions
aujourd'hui près de 15 jours de débats
consacrés à la défense à nos armées et à
travers elle à celles et ceux qui chaque
jour portent haut et fort les couleurs
de notre pays pour assurer notre
protection je voudrais également avoir
une pensée pour les Ukrainiens qui se
battent toujours pour leur pays pour
leur liberté et pour défendre les
valeurs qui nous sont chères comme l'ont
récemment rien démontré d'ailleurs les
annonces du président de la République
la France est à leur côté et les
soutiendra tant que nécessaire
l'examen en commission est venu rappeler
utilement que le budget des armées ne
sera pas imputé par l'aide que nous
continuerons d'apporter aux Ukrainiens
ainsi malgré l'importance de ce soutien
l'ambition de moderniser nos armées que
nous portons à vos côtés monsieur le
ministre reste intacte avec ce budget de
413 milliards d'euros et chers collègues
il nous faut penser pour une fois autant
long
nous sommes tous conscients que cet
argent représente un effort important
pour la nation nous sommes aussi
conscients que cette somme a pu attirer
de nombreuses convoitises quant à son
utilisation aussi personne ne s'étonne
de voir ce qui aspire à gouverner dans
quelques années proposé d'avancer dès
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
investissements sans se soucier du poids
pour notre dépense publique mais surtout
sans se soucier de l'adaptation à notre
modèle de l'armée l'imparable
démonstration de leurs illusions a été
faite par le Ministre en commission avec
un mot d'ordre qui sera celui de mon
groupe pour les jours à venir sur ce
texte la cohérence
car c'est en toute cohérence qu'il a
d'abord été demandé aux armées leurs
besoins pour construire au mieux un
budget ambitieux qui sera porté après de
69 milliards d'euros par an d'ici 2030
au plus haut depuis 3 décennies c'est en
cohérence avec notre stratégie à long
terme portée depuis 60 ans que nous
continuons d'investir dans notre
dissuasion garante de notre indépendance
et de la place de la France dans le
monde c'est encore incohérence avec le
modèle d'armée que nous souhaitons
léguer que nous actionons les
investissements vers les enjeux
essentiels des conflits de haute
intensité à venir le spatial le cyber
les drones mais aussi plus simplement
les musiciens les munitions pardon et le
maintien en condition opérationnelle
c'est enfin en cohérence avec l'objectif
de demeurer un partenaire fidèle que
nous garantissons la place de la France
comme nation cadre de l'OTAN tout en
renforçant l'autonomie stratégique
européenne au travers de parten la
solide et mutuellement bénéfique tels
que le Scaff le mgcs et de nombreux
autres coopérations européennes je
formule aussi le vœu au nom des députés
démocrates que ces coopérations
européennes continuent à se développer
tant elle renforce l'indépendance de
notre continent et à travers lui celui
de la France je le sais nos débats
reviendront sur l'enjeu de ces alliances
ceux qui pensent renforcer la France
tout en la sortant des partenariats qui
font sa force et maintiennent son
influence se retrouveront face à
l'évidence de leur contradiction on ne
peut espérer demeurer une puissance de
premier rang sans pouvoir compter sur le
fidèle alliés au-delà de ces questions
matérielles et stratégiques cette LPM
porte une ambition nouvelle pour
renforcer le lien armée nation et les
mens central auquel mon groupe portera
une attention particulière nous devons
collectivement encourager nos
concitoyens à retrouver le sens de
l'engagement pour leur pays quel que
soit que ce soit au niveau de nos
réserves ou pour les avec le SNU madame
la secrétaire d'État la compréhension
des enjeux de notre sécurité mais
surtout des valeurs qui nous unissent
c'est une étape essentielle pour bâtir
une nation forte et résiliente face aux
crises il y a en fait la reconnaissance
la reconnaissance de celle et ceux qui
consacrent leur vie à protéger notre
pays leur engagement doit évidemment
continuer à être valorisé et nous y
serons très vigilants dans l'application
de cette loi mais aussi la
reconnaissance de celles et ceux qui
partagent la vie de ces militaires ils
vivent eux aussi au rythme de l'armée
parfois au détriment de la au détriment
du leurre nous continuerons de
travailler pour faire reconnaître ce qui
doit être vu comme leur engagement pour
la nation je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer
le plan blessé présenté récemment par
Patricia mirales qui prend en compte
toutes les situations et leur
implication au quotidien pour ses
blessés mais aussi pour leur famille
ainsi notre assemblée devra rester
attentive aux avancées promues dans le
texte et nous nous réjouissons des
pouvoirs de contrôle dans le Parlement
disposera pour effectuer ce travail
aussi si nous souhaitons apporter encore
quelques améliorations à ce texte au
travers de nos différents amendements le
groupe démocrate soutiendra bien
évidemment cette LPM historique je vous
remercie